and the Oscar goes to I was sitting
there at the Academy Awards mining my
own business my category came up I
remember Javier bardam and uh joh brolan
coming out I remember them saying my
name Aon and the
[Applause]
[Music]
network this is the first Academy Award
and nomination for Aaron Sor I walked
down the aisle I hugged Jesse Eisenberg
I walked on
stage I was pretty numb uh at the time
they put an Oscar in my
hand uh thank you I've never watched it
I think I said what I wanted to say it's
impossible to describe what it feels
like to be handed the same award that
was given to Patty chyy 35 years ago for
another movie with network in the title
I thanked not nearly enough people but
uh as as many people as I could there
are a lot of people who've worked hard
in my corner for a long time and it
seems like the right moment to thank
them my assistant Lauren lman my
researcher Ian rback
my long-suffering press rep uh Joy F and
all the women of prime want to give a
special shout out to my daughter uh who
was 9 years old Roxy sorin your father
just won the Academy Award I'm going to
have to insist on some respect from your
guinea pig thank you very much it really
wasn't until I walked off stage that I
realized what had just happened it's a
night I'll never
forget